we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P speaking of Joe Rogan
this is a voicemail that brings up a
really important issue which we've not
talked about too much take a listen
hi David I was just watching uh one of
your clips about Joe Rogan talking about
the monoclonal antibodies
I just wonder why no one is actually
talking about the listed possible side
effects on regeneron's website yeah
bodies
everybody wants to talk about possible
side effects for a vaccine but nobody
seems to want to talk about the possible
side effects from the monoclonal
antibodies
maybe you should check that out this is
a very important point so we've talked
before there's a group that is
either against
or skeptical of the vaccines
partially on the basis that we have this
great treatment monoclonal antibodies
that's once you get covered so first of
all of course
I prefer prevention rather than cures as
a general thing so we have to even
separate the antibody treatment and
vaccines on that basis but when you look
at the claims made about the vaccine
that these antibody supporters don't
make about the antibody treatment they
say well the vaccine is experimental the
Pfizer vaccine is fully approved by the
FDA whereas the monoclonal antibodies
are only approved by emergency use
authorization that's not a good argument
they say well I don't trust big Pharma
which is why I'm against the vaccines
the antibody treatment is also made by
big Pharma so that's not a good argument
they say well there's a financial
incentive on the vaccination well it is
far less profitable to do a regimen of
three doses of vaccine than it is to do
a regimen of the monoclonal antibodies
we're talking about thousands of dollars
versus under a hundred total full cost
for a full regimen of vaccines so the
financial argument also doesn't make
sense but then you get to the side
effects and The Advocates of the
antibodies instead of the vaccine never
talk about the list of possible side
effects and I'm going to tell you what
they are this is for the antibody
treatment fever chills nausea headache
shortness of breath low blood pressure
or high blood pressure rapid heartbeat
or slow heartbeat chest discomfort and
pain weakness confusion tired wheezing
lip swelling face swelling throat
swelling rashes including hives itching
muscle aches feeling faint dizzy and or
sweaty
these reactions may be severe or
life-threatening you may experience new
or worsening symptoms after receiving
the treatment including fever breathing
difficulty and some of the other things
that I mentioned it is unknown if these
symptoms are because of the treatment or
because the progression of covid could
be affected and exacerbated exacerbated
by the antibody treatment you also
because it is an intravenous therapy you
can have pain bleeding skin bruising
soreness swelling and even infection
where you have that iv put in these are
not all the possible side effects of the
antibody treatment not a lot of people
have been given the antibody treatment
says regeneron compared to uh hundreds
of millions of people who have been
given the vaccine it also is disclaimed
and stipulated by regeneron that the
covid monoclonal antibody treatment
could interfere with your own body's
ability to fight off future Covenant
infections and reduce your immune
response to vaccination against
coronavirus that is a mouthful
and all of these people saying well the
vaccine's experimental so are the
antibodies uh but and and no longer is
the vaccine experimental at least not
the Pfizer uh and I don't I don't want
those side effects from the vaccine look
at the list of possible side effects
from the monoclonal antibody treatment
I'm not against the treatment when it is
the appropriate treatment it can be a
really great thing works better than
Placebo you've got to be sick though I
would prefer not to get sick in the
first place but a very good voicemail
and an important topic and yet another
thing to keep in mind about those
advocating for the monoclonal antibodies
instead of the vaccine when they are two
completely different things the
antibodies are a tool if you get sick
uh but we have other tools to try to
prevent us from getting sick in the
first place on the bonus show today we
will talk about the gilen Maxwell guilty
verdicts five out of six uh charges we
will talk about States hoarding welfare
funds even as the need for Aid grows and
we are going to talk about the imminent
increase of the California minimum wage
to 15 dollars per hour all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com